in the lobby of ramsy solutions Andy and
Brooke are with us hey guys how are you
we're doing great welcome welcome where
yall from akan Pennsylvania cool welcome
to Nashville and here to do a debt free
scream yes so how much have you paid off
a little over 70,000 very cool I love it
and how long did that take you it took
it was a span of six years uh and
there's reasons for that I guess we'll
get into when we share our story okay
and uh income during range during that
time we went from 40 to approximately 88
okay very cool good for you way to go
way to go way to go so tell me the story
then what's the what's the what's the
journey like well uh several years ago
we ended up purchasing some homes on a
home AC L of credit for rental
properties and of course the market took
a crash of course and we tried to ride
that out and didn't want to go down the
four Ure or any of that that rout um but
that's where we ended up going so that
we could save our home and um so that
process took some time we were stuck in
the small home that we've we had for
almost 13 years um and in the process we
heard about you and we start looking at
what debts we did have and um here we
are ready to Door our screen we took our
we took our first FPU class about six
years ago and uh a few months mons
before we took that class we had
purchased our a newer vehicle of course
on a monthly payment plan this was pre
Dave Ramsey and uh when once we finished
the class we realized that we didn't
want to be debt free or we wanted to be
debt free and uh we wanted to pursue
that Journey so we sort of rode the wave
we were committed but not 100% and then
one day I was in the office paying bills
and I looked at our home equity line of
credit bill and I was like well this
thing hasn't gone down at all what
what's going on here so I called and and
I realized the big mistake we made is
this uh line of credit we took out on a
insurance
only uh payment plan and and I I my
heart just sunk interest only interest
only sorry interest only payment plan my
heart sunk at more at our stupidity than
anything we I I'm like how can we have
been so stupid so that was
$36,000 and we nailed that out in 23
months um we did have a $6,000 gift from
somebody but the 30,000 we paid off in
23 months and then from there to now we
just plowed through it boom now have you
paid off your first mortgage as well we
sold our home our first home back in
October M and uh we just purchased a new
home in December then okay and then um
we had a $7,000 uh tax bill come up this
this past tax season uh we paid that off
and since then you know we're officially
debt free except for our house and we'll
pay that off quickly I love it so you
went through through Financial Peace
University 6 years ago and that starts
this whole journey yep wow and you've
been coordinating the class I understand
we and how many classes have you
coordinated we I think we guessed about
15 or 16 classes that we did and you're
like professionals far from it wow so
why would I mean so you've used that
class just to keep you going too haven't
you oh absolutely it's huge help every
time we coordinate it's you know we're
at a different step in our journey we
see things differently we hear things ly
and it it just keeps keeps pushing us
along inspires you along along with you
you've got great stories for your
classes absolutely wow well thank you
for doing that with such diligence wow
we're honored very very neat very fun
I'm so proud of you guys thank it's a
long journey was it worth it absolutely
amen yeah God I think he just blessed
our efforts um more than we ever could
have imagined yeah I mean because you've
been through the ringer I mean you've
been through everything here that's a
lot of miles in six years it really is
and to stick with it for 6 years that's
very cool so now that you're oldtime big
time coordinators teaching the class 16
times and you're debt-free the next
class somebody's going to be in there
and they're going to be scared and
they're going to or they're going to be
belligerent or they going to be
something and they're going to ask that
question so how did you get out of that
what do you tell them the keys are well
we wrote it down rice and beans and
beans and rice uh saying no to a lot of
lot of great things that come along
friends and family want to do vacations
this this is our first family vacation
we made it ever here ever ever and how
long have you all been married 13 years
Y and uh our kids our oldest is almost
10 and we've never taken a family
weeklong vacation and here you are in
Nashville well we're honored to have you
very neat so the kids names and ages are
what our oldest uh son is MacGyver he
will be 10 in just a few weeks uh next
is Maverick is eight and our daughter is
four and her name is Kiana okay are they
going to help us with a debt free screen
okay guys get them into the camera now
we're going to give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's book retire inspired because
that's the next step baby step four now
you're debt free get the emergency fund
in place and now you're ready to go I
mean so you're ready to go off and be
retire inspired and live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else I'm so proud of you
guys congratulations and thank you thank
you thank you for teaching the class and
being such a blessing to so many
Families how many I mean 160 180
families over 16 classes wow that's a
lot that's amazing probably 200 I mean
there's not telling how many people in
there that's amazing so congratulations
all right Andy Brook MacGyver Maverick
and K caleana count it down Philadelphia
$70,000 paid off in six years count it
down let's hear your debt free Scream 3
2 1 we're de
free
yay
H Wow way to go you guys way to go man
that is awesome hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the Subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and w
fired up that your broke friends think
you've lost your mind
[Music]